on my last video about doing a physics
degree I got a lot of questions about
what I did and what I'm doing now so I'm
going to talk about that today the last
three years I spent in Christchurch
studying my undergraduate degree I did a
Bachelor of Science majoring in physics
and mathematics
I found it overall to be a really
challenging three years but also pretty
rewarding the things that challenged me
were doing subjects that I wasn't
necessarily that comfortable with so in
terms of math I'd sort of liked that at
high school but never been the best at
it and when I went to uni I didn't
really intend to major in math it's just
something that sort of happened in the
sense that in the first layer mask
courses I did I got good marks and I
enjoyed doing them so I just kept doing
more math courses and that actually led
to having enough to count all of the
major my focus was always though on the
physics the sort of topics that can
inspire me going into the degree with
those really interesting parts of
physics like quantum mechanics and also
aspects of astrophysics and I think I
was inspired by those mostly because
those are the topics that you hear about
in popular science books or on TV and
documentaries whether it's that those
subjects seem to have the best PR
campaigns or if they are inherently the
most interesting I'm not sure but
they're definitely what inspired me
going in studying in first year I found
to be the easiest because I kind of
stayed in the same routine I'd had in
high school so I was living in a hole
and a lot of people in my classes with
me and I had sort of been motivated by
them to study
and also the classes were really big I
found that when the classes became
smaller and the further years and I had
sort of less friends of living around me
that was studying them I had to be a lot
more self-motivated also those first
year courses they had like sort of the
pillar courses for physics and math and
the coursework kind of resembled that
from high school so it wasn't that much
new content to take on and if anything
the ideas were the same it was like
mechanics or electromag a little bit of
modern physics just like I'd done in
high school but just more in-depth one
of the differences going to uni from
high school that was maybe a challenging
thing to come to terms with was sort of
that level of competition that I
personally felt coming into it I'd been
at a small high school and had always
sort of been the top of my class just
because not many people were studying
science or very serious about it then
going into uni they were sort of a lot
of people that were really focused a lot
that word but it was totally a different
environment if you were used to being
the top of your class and then having to
compete with a bunch of people who are
also used to that I definitely have a
lot of stressful moments during the
degree I am the kind of person that does
things at the last minute so for every
test but the whole way through I would
basically cram beforehand and in
hindsight I know that's not a good thing
to do and I miss a lot of things I look
back on I wish I remembered the more and
that I had really taken the time to
learn them and dips but I just didn't I
just couldn't find the time to do that I
just had to sort of memorize chunks of
material that I knew would be relevant
for the exam and then use that I don't
think though doing that was a total
waste though because it enabled me to
get through to get
good grades to keep going and I was
exposed to that material to a level of
understanding that I could go and read
about it again if I wanted to explore
and more in-depth also definitely the
thing that helped me the most studying
was having good friends that are
studying the same thing as you and that
you can actually study in groups with
and bounce ideas off each other all the
courses I hated the most were probably
because I didn't have many friends in
those classes and I always felt like I
was battling the subject matter alone
when you don't have that sense of being
alone you feel like you're part of a
group of people trying to figure things
out together and that you can explain
things to each other that's where I
always learn the most so I definitely
did at times consider if physics was the
right thing for me all the way through
up until I graduated I would think
should I have done something else this
is this the right fit for me because
like I said it was a very challenging
degree the things I probably thought
about changing into included computer
science and psychology or biology so
still in that science area I always that
was for me I loved that the scientific
thinking so I had friends that went into
computer science who also interested in
physics and it's it's an area where
there
seemingly a lot more job opportunities
and coming out of a physics degree I
feel sort of less prepared to go
straight into industry work the way that
you kind of get that feeling coming out
with coding skills
I definitely like I did computer science
courses a long way in fact that the
coding courses I did in first and second
year about data structures and
algorithms though I learned so much in
those courses
I really enjoy doing them the people
were really great that's why I sort of
tempted to go further down that road but
then I look back at why I went into
physics about the questions that i
wanted to solve and then the field I
wanted to be involved in and it didn't
really match with going down the
computer science road and then with the
biology or the psychology those are sort
of other sciences that kind of appeal to
more of a almost the creative side of me
there are fields that have a lot more
woman studying them than physics or
masters is the idea I guess that I
thought I'd be better at writing essays
and psychology or memorizing words for
biology and processes then I would be as
solving heid mathematical equations and
I I think it was maybe a lack of
confidence there that made me want to
switch but again I thought back to why I
really wanted to do physics and the
mysteries and things that draw me to it
and I'm glad that I have started with it
because as I've gone along I've I've
always tried to stay true to that the
reason of why I did it in the first
place and I think that's led me to where
I am now and I'm doing what I'm doing
now which is physics research and I
think I'm in the right place so unlike
the American system where I know you
have to sort of take courses outside of
your major your area
I wasn't required to take any courses
that weren't physics or maths and with
the exception of one psychology course
all of my courses were physics maths and
some computer science but that was sort
of related as a requirement for the
physics because in physics you do you do
code quite a bit not in the same way as
computer scientists we're not building
sort of websites or things that people
use
we're coding simulations for our
experiments ways to plot and understand
experimental data there were some
courses that I did which were
technically math courses although they
were kind of outside the square so I did
a history of mathematics course which
was really interesting as spoke about
not only the history of of how different
cultures used math in different ways but
it spoke about how math is a
communication tool how math has been
used by different cultures and their
poetry and communication and also we
looked at paradoxes sort of classic
ideas at the foundations of math that
make you sort of question everything
there is definitely a lot of math in
physics and that can be scary to a lot
of people like I said I didn't really
anticipate doing a lot of maths more
than what was at least necessary but I
ended up really enjoying the way that
university maths was taught and really
becoming more involved with maths than I
ever had been before I still am almost
limited by my own confidence and maths
it's almost kind of embarrassed that I
have a degree in maths now but I still
struggle with it and definitely more
than other people in my cohort did but
it doesn't have to be something that
holds you back if you can find an
underlying interests and the ideas that
you were studying then you can sort of
push through em and pick up each of the
necessary math skills for each paper
that you're doing it takes a long time
to be able to tie those together and I'm
still working on that but I don't think
if you struggle with maths that you
should let it hold you back after my
three year bachelor degree I could have
walked away and tried to get a job and
not study you anymore I definitely
consider that I I was feeling a bit low
when I sort of finished
my last exams I was feeling low in my
self-confidence and also my motivation
to to keep going that out but something
that I found hard however I was
fortunate enough to come to Australia
for a summer scholarship program so I
was doing research last summer and I was
paired with a supervisor who I really
sort of connected with Anna I really
enjoy the research project enough to
sign up to come back for my honours here
which is basically a research here
you're not it's it's separate from your
undergraduate but it's less than a PhD
it's kind of a pathway in-between and
I'm currently doing research I'm doing
it in an area that it's an intersection
between physics and biology I'm looking
at how Katherine sneaked plant cells and
I'm doing this by mimicking pathogens
using nanotechnology I'm basically
applying very small pressures to plant
cells and then measuring their response
on the nano scale I'll be doing this
until halfway through next year and
after that I could go on to do a PhD at
this point though I don't know what I'll
do
thinking back to why I chose physics in
the first place is their thing that
keeps me motivated just to stay in it
and when I doubt myself or doubt the
subject that's what brings me back so
why I chose physics is that it excites
me in a way that other subjects don't so
it was really through basically TV
documentaries and online video that I
fostered an interest in physics I had
sort of no interest in my high school
physics class or the teacher or subject
matter I found it completely boring I
wasn't interested in finding the forces
something rolling down the slope what I
was interested in was reading about
theories of how I guess the universe
expands or how you can measure style
eight
and if I hadn't been exposed to those
but pretty much online video materials
then I wouldn't have been inspired by my
classwork thinking about physics is
really thinking about the most inherent
aspect of the world around us it's how
things work it's being able to look at
something in nature or a system and try
to understand the intricate parts that
that go towards how that thing happens
or why things are the way they are
having a physics perspective makes me
critical about the world around me and
also I think it allows me to find beauty
and the things around me
I've been asked if I thought doing the
math major as well as the physics one
was worth it I'd probably say if if you
if you're studying for physics don't go
out of your way to try and to try and
get math major just for the sake of it I
did it because the math courses going
forward like in second and third year of
my degree I just found them really
interesting I wanted to do them I wanted
to be exposed to things like group
theory and other sort of more abstract
ideas in this I wouldn't say you it's
definitely not necessary to go forward
and research anything else and in fact I
don't think people care what degree you
have if if you have an interest in
physics and at least the way that the
PhD scheme works in Australia is that if
you've demonstrated skill and interest
in a particular area and you're keen to
go on and pursue research and if you've
got some good grades and you're
passionate people don't really care what
the words are on your degree on your
certificate they care about who you are
and whether they think you'll make a
good researcher or a good member of
their team so I didn't need
the math major for anything I just have
it because I was interested in that
thanks for everyone who left comments or
questions on my last video about a
physics degree if you have any more
please leave them on this video or send
me a message I'd be happy to talk to you
about my experiences studying physics